in sports athletes can determine who's
best by marking who runs faster jumps
higher hits harder makes the highest
scores or in golf the lowest but in art
who's a determine that a van Gogh oil is
better than a Picasso charcoal and a
music a Strauss waltz is better than a
Gershwin ballad and in food that beef
wellington is better than a cup of
yogurt
you know maybe went a little too far but
in acting who says one's performance is
better than another the actors branch
the Academy has always nominated five
gifted women and as always the agonizing
final decision was left to our entire
membership the nominees are Geena Davis
in Thelma and Louise Laura Dern in
ramblin rose
Jodie Foster in the Silence of the Lambs
Bette Midler in for the boys
Susan Sarandon in Thelma & Louise
and the Oscar goes to Jodie Foster
silence of the Lamb
ah this has been such an incredible year
and I'd like to dedicate this award to
all of the women who came before me who
never had the chances that I've had and
the survivors and the pioneers and the
outcasts and my blood my tradition and
I'd like to thank all of the people in
this industry who have respected my
choices and who have not been afraid of
the power and the dignity that that
entitled me to and I'd like to thank Ted
Talley and Thomas Harris Jesse Kornbluth
everybody to Ryan the way it used to be
and the way will always be in my heart
John Douglas and everybody at Quantico
the incredible cast and crew of silence
in the Lambs that Jonathan put together
and of course the reason that I'm here
yeah Anthony Hopkins quid pro quo doctor
and my guru
Jonathan Demi not just for his talent
but for his goodness I promise you and
I'd like to thank my team of people the
only people I talk to every single day
my agent and friend Joe Funicello thank
you and Matt saber Pat Kingsley I'd like
to thank my family and my family of
friends the trusted ones the circle and
most of all I'd like to thank my mother
Brandi my friend the person who has
loved me so much and so well that she
taught me an inimitable little man Tate
fashioned to fly away thank you and
thank the Academy for embracing such an
incredibly strong and beautiful feminist
hero that I am so proud of thank you
very much Mike and Carol you won the bet
right on
you